Our Father in Heaven as I try in my
human way to answer questions let your
spirit direct my mind I pray bless us
all with truth in Jesus name amen before
I take your questions I want to deal
with one or two that have come to me
over time one of them is is melchisedec
Christ or is melchisedek God I've heard
that over and over some people believe
melchisedec is Christ let's take a look
reasonably the Bible says come now let
us do what reason together the Bible is
not a book of proof it is a book of
evidence where is proof there's no need
for Faith amen where there's evidence
faith is required but Faith biblical
faith is not blind the evidence of the
Bible points in a certain direction and
if someone reads it honestly that person
will follow that direction all right let
us go to Deuteronomy
18 we're answering the question is
melchisedec
Christ in case you fall asleep let me
tell you no immediately but let's go to
Deuteronomy
18 while you're looking for Deuteronomy
18 tell me the three offices of Christ
Prophet priest is that the order
yes when he came he was a right now he's
a he eventually he'll be a all right
we're looking at his role as a prophet
Deuteronomy 18 we read from verse 15
when you found it say amen amen read
with me what does that say the Lord thy
God shall raise up unto thee of thy
Brethren a prophet like unto me him he
shall here Moses prophesied that God
would raise up a prophet to his people
like
Moses notice he said like unto me so
Moses is saying I am the
type you not with me like unto me so I
am a
type and whoever he is will be the anti
mhm go to Acts chapter
3 by the God bless all the children who
gave the verses thank you very much and
continue to read God's word and love it
amen and the adults thank you as
well acts 23 not not 23 sorry Acts 3 we
read 22 and
26 read with me what does it say for
Moses truly said unto the fathers a
prophet shall the Lord your God raise up
unto you come on of your breath and lie
unto me does that sound familiar yes
he's quoted from Deuteronomy 18:15 Now
read 26 unto you first God had raised up
his son Jesus sent him to bless you now
who is the prophet Moses spoke about
Jesus which means the prophetic model
for Christ work as a prophet was
Moses I didn't say that clearly let me
say differently the Old Testament type
of the prophetic Ministry of Christ was
Moses go to the Book of Luke chapter
1 Luke chapter
1 and Moses was not
God you have Luke 1 this is the Angel
telling uh Mary about the son she would
have let's read verse 32 the angel
Gabriel is speaking to Mary a shocked
Mary you have 32 read with me and he
shall be
uhhuh the son of the highest and the
Lord shall give unto him come on the
throne of his father David the Lord
shall give unto him when Christ finally
sits enthroned he will be sitting on the
throne of his father David go on next
verse and he shall House of for and of
his kingdom they shall be so this
kingship will last forever it's the
kingship of David that Christ will
inherit now the Old Testament type of
Christ's kingship is whom David's
rule David's rule is the Old Testament
type when Christ sits on the throne it
will the antitype the Fulfillment he
will reign forever amen go to Hebrews 5
and David was not
God Hebrews
5 and it's also mentioned about three
times in chapter
7 let's read 9 and 10 of Hebrews 5 what
does that
say and being made perfect he became the
author of Eternal salvation unto that
pause a minute unto all them that obey
him and I want to
digress obedience is too set aside in
this modern world we are too offended by
the word obey Christ is the author of
Eternal salvation unto them that obey
him go to acts 5 quickly as I still
digress Acts chapter 5
let's read this is Peter speaking to the
Sanhedrin they they were surprised that
those guys were still preaching about
Jesus now let's read verse 32 here's
what Peter says of Acts chapter 5 read
with me and we are his Witnesses of
these things and so is also the Holy
Ghost whom God has given to them that
obey him
Jesus is the author of Salvation to
those that obey him the Holy Ghost is
given to those that obey
him amen I just wanted to stress obey
now we get back to Hebrews 5 let's read
nine again and being made perfect he
became the author of Eternal salvation
unto that oh read verse 10 now called of
God I praise as after the order of
melchisedec now after the order is no
different from Moses saying like unto me
are you with me light unto me is the
same as after the order now the Old
Testament model for the priesthood of
Christ is whom
M let's review the Old Testament model
for Christ's prophetic Ministry wases
Moses and Moses was not God the Old
Testament model for the kingship of
Christ was David and David is not God
the Old Testament model for his
priesthood is why should mzc be God if
any one of the three Moses melkisedek
David had to be God it should be David
I'll tell you why because Christ's
ministry as a prophet it
ended it ended when he left this Earth
he's no longer a prophet yes what is he
now a priest will that end yes will his
kingship end
no so if one of the three had to be a
god it should be David not mesc because
what he symbolizes will end when we hear
the Declaration he that is Holy let him
be holy still melkisedek is not God
people think he is simply because his
genealogy is not recorded but the fact
that something is not recorded does not
mean it doesn't exist let me give an
example of that go to Psalm
106 Psalm
106 you have Psalm 106 amen read verse
17 for read 16 and 17 of Psalm now Psalm
106 is called a historical Psalm also
Psalm 105
10778 136 they are historical Psalms
they all deal with God's interactions
with the Israelites from Egypt to the
promised land now Psalm
1066 what does that say they envied
Moses also in the camp and Aaron the
saint of the Lord the word envy mean
they challenge his
leadership who challenge his leadership
Kora come Onan come on and a b those
three read verse 17 the Earth opened and
swallowed up
uh-huh what do you
notice Kora is not mentioned but if you
read number 16 Kora went down with them
so when if Kora is not mentioned you
simply fill in the
blind based on other information go to
number
16 number
16 let's read from verse
one book number four
numbers you have that Read With Me Now
Kora the son of isar the son of Kath the
son of Levi and Dayan and abum the sons
of elab and on the son of PB sons of
Reuben took men and they rose up before
Moses with certain of the children of
Israel 250 princes of the assembly
famous in the congregation men of renown
and they gathered themselves together
against Moses and against Aaron and said
unto them ye take too much upon you
seeing all the congregation Are Holy
every one of them and the Lord is among
them wherefore then lift ye up
yourselves above the congregation of the
Lord and when Moses heard it he fell
upon his face
now Kora Dayan and ab those three when
you read Psalm
10617 that the Earth opened up and
swallowed death and a Byam the author
simply perhaps just forgot to write Kora
but you have to know where you see Dayan
and
abam let me give you an example of non-
mentioned does not mean
non-existent are you with me the fact is
not mentioned does not mean it doesn't
exist go
to Genesis 14 no no no not Genesis 14 go
to Jude verse 7 the book of Jude is
found just before revelation
and just
after third John
okay give you a little headache there
for
minute they're well known yes well known
well
respected M within the yes yes
MH It's usually the influential people
who cause trouble all right do you have
Jude yes verse 7 let me pray again
father continue to speak to us clearly
in Jesus name I pray amen read with me
even as Sodom and Gomorrah and the
cities about them in like manner giving
themselves over to fornication and going
after strange flesh as set for for an
example suffering the Vengeance of
Eternal now when you think of wicked
cities who comes to mind yeah throughout
the but there were five of them yes were
read verse against Heaven even as Sodom
and gor carefully now and the cities
about them in like manner just as wicked
but the Bible writers don't want to keep
saying Sodom Gomorrah adma and ba so
they pick two these represent the wicked
cities of the plain the same way Gog and
MOG represent All Nations opposed to
God but you can't list all of them so
Gog and MOG represents All Nations
opposed to God let me give you a
practical example what state are we in
ten Tennesse all right now I am going to
ask you to identify a state but I'll
only mention some
cities and you tell me what state I'm
thinking of are you with me are you
ready Nashville
Tennessee do I need to name all the
cities in Tennessee no when you hear
Nashville you hear Tennessee are you
with me when you hear Sodom and gorah
you hear adma Zabo and ba now go to
Genesis
14 so don't believe because something's
not mentioned it doesn't exist it must
have a prior existence somewhere in the
Bible and does not need to be repeated
over and over again Genesis 14 we'll
read from verse
one are you there read with me now we
came to pass in the days of am Rafel
king of China AR king of aler K ARA king
of Elam and title king of Nations
carefully now that these made war with
barah king of Sodom and with Bersa king
of Gomorrah shab king of adma shba king
of Zabo and the king of ba which is zor
now how many cities
five five all five were Wicked we know
that from Jude verse 7 even as Sodom and
gamorra and the cities about them in
like
manner when you read the Bible use
this you're Noggin you ever heard the
word Noggin this and
concentrate now the fact that M mdc's
genealogy is not mentioned does not mean
he did not have one the only person who
ever walked this Earth without a
genealogy is Jesus Christ prior to him
coming as a baby in Mary's womb so mzc
David Moses there are are types of
Christ prophetic Priestly and kingly
offices amen none of those three are God
only Christ is God all right let's take
now make your questions
easy I'm serious and as you C question
think of others will they benefit or is
this just for me if it's just for you I
understand but
will this benefit people largely let me
tell you questions I have no interest in
but I can't tell you what to
ask should the pastor's wife wear high
heels you know
uh what
else said a woman wear pants
and um what
else um women's ordination you know I
don't want to Riot let's there's some
biblical questions righteousness just
ification the second coming the nature
of Christ the nature of the Holy Spirit
these are recommendations but you can
ask what you want are you with me
there's a mic right here there's a mic
right there you're first
come yes good evening good evening this
morning you T about the heart partially
given to God how someone can understand
that he's in the state or not that he's
what in the state of not giving all his
heart oh very good thank you what's your
name corali who sister Nelson sister
Nelson yes why did you not give the
other name
again okay sister
Nelson there
is there is a how does a person know he
or she has not given the entire life to
Christ it's a partial
surrender El white writes in the book
Ministry of healing page 480 paragraph 3
many who profess to be Christ's
followers have an anxious trouble heart
because they are afraid to trust
themselves to him they do not make a
complete surrender for they shrink from
the consequences that such a surrender
requires unless they make this surrender
they cannot have peace what I'm saying
to my sister is if you find yourself
struggling worrying
distressed it could be you have not
totally surrendered listen to me a total
surrender is not very popular it's very
uncommon otherwise said genuine
conversion is
rare he also tells us if we would
surrender to God the way Jesus did we
would do what he
did and so feelings of unease
uncertainty doubt those are evidences
you may not have entirely surrendered to
God are there small areas where you and
God have an
argument when you're totally surrendered
it is what do you want what do you want
what do you want not that you don't have
your own desires but like Christ
nevertheless not my will but thine in
every area large and small what do you
want Total
surrender amen so whatever you do you
think of God you go to the supermarket
you shop like a
Believer you go to buy a dress or a suit
you buy it like a
Believer you go wherever you conduct
yourself like a Believer you're always
conscious I am alive for one primary
reason to glorify God the Bible tells us
in Isaiah 43:7 thou has created him for
my
glory and so uncertainty
doubt anxiety our evidence is that the
surrender is not
complete the three Hebrew boys standing
before that fire they said our God whom
we serve is able to Deliver Us From The
Burning fiery furnace and he will
deliver us out of thy hand oh King but
if not be it known unto thee Oh King we
will not serve thy Gods nor worship the
golden image which thou Hast set up and
they're saying that they can feel the
heat total surrender amen am I am not
bothered by the possibility of walking
into a furnace Daniel knew what was
awaiting him if he prayed to his God but
he prayed and he went to the Lion's
total
surrender somebody else thank
you uh you got to come to the
mic yes my good
brother brother with Isaiah 574 15 yes
go ahead I pray that
no one gets angry at me for asking this
question
um we we know in Ezekiel 4:6 and in
Deuteronomy that a day equals a year in
Bible prophecy it is stated to be a
principle yet in the Old Testament I
read about the 400 years of of Israel
being in captivity right I read a 7 the
years that they would be in captivity I
read of uh uh Pharaoh's dream of seven
years of the Corn and the Animals I read
of the
um uh Vision I mean the dreams of the
Butler and and the uh
Baker and my question is these were not
interpreted in Day for year princip able
even though they were prophecies how do
you determine what prophecies are day
for a year and what are not Day for year
well okay I've never heard that question
interesting question the situation with
the Butler and the Baker and uh uh the
seven cows and seven ears of corn there
were not apocalyptic
prophecies an apocalyptic prophecy has
to do with end time those were not
apocalyptic prophecies the year they
principes is applied largely to
apocalyptic prophecies the 1260 the 2300
1335 1290 the four 90 uh 70 weeks it
determin those are apocalyptic
prophecies but that restricted event of
the Baker and the Butler and uh a couple
other you mentioned they are not
apocalyptic prophecies they are uh local
restricted
prophecies they did not extend beyond
Egypt and so the year they doesn't apply
to them it applies to apocalypse that's
why you find that in Daniel and
Revelation those prophecies largely are
the ones where the year their principle
uh numbers Ezekiel 46 uh numbers what
1434 apply but I've never heard that
interesting question about the 70 year
prophecy of captivity the 70y year
prophecy activity that's not apocalyptic
Ida that was very restricted very local
It came it went and that's that's not a
part of the Prophecies of Daniel and
Revelation it is a prophecy but not an
apocalyptic prophecy it's apply to
apocalyptic prophecies 2300 days 1290
1335 uh 490 that's my best response but
I'll do some reading on that very
interesting question
M yes oh sister come to the mic it's
just a personal question what does your
devotional look life look like the
Bible it's all
day
um first thing I do when I open my eye
is recite a particular Psalm I won't say
which one and because I try to say that
one about three times a day that's the
first one the first thing I do um then
all during the day and I mean all during
the day I'm going through verses asking
what does this mean what does that mean
because I have so many appointments I'm
always trying to figure out how can I
present this sermon differently
and so if I'm showering if I'm driving
I'm in the gym I am in the gym may have
heard this in my sermons if I do a set
of bench presses when I'm finished I sit
down I recite a Bible passage instead of
just I recite a about maybe Revelation
15 just eight verses and each time I me
pick one chap one passage recite it
between every set whether Squad a bench
press curl and so that the word now is
on my head on my head but my devotion is
constantly during the day I remember my
wife and I were driving somewhere and
she said can I talk to you I said you
don't have to ask me she said well I
know you're going through the Bible so I
don't want to disturb you no you have a
license to disturb anytime you want and
so it's that's the way I do
it I'm always thinking how can I present
this or how can I answer an
attack I've asked God can I tell you
promise to keep this
secret you don't look trustworthy or you
promise
El white says in the time of trouble
some people will be arrested yes taken
to court we'll have to defend the truth
and while they're defending the truth
people listening will take this stand
for the truth when I read that I said oh
my father please let me be one so for
years I prayed to God
please let me be arrested not let me
cause trouble just let me be arrested
taken to court and defend the teachings
We Believe amen I want to see the
Fulfillment of that prophecy people in
the courtroom accepting Christ as I
defend the truth I want God to give me
that am
M uh so that's yes all day really is all
day on a plane wherever all day yes and
L's
quotations mhm God bless you
who oh yes my brother okay we have a
question that came from online online
and I just wanted to comment on the
previous question also usually when
there's a prophecy God has to tell us it
is symbolic when you see when the angel
came to Daniel the angel was the one
that put that time in symbolic uh
numbers if it's not put in that context
it's not for us to make up that's why
people sometimes say the Earth was
created in 7,000 years because it says
for God a day is like a year so God is
the one that tells us when it's symbolic
or not okay this is a question that came
online it
says I don't know if it just falls on
the ones that you think don't ask or ask
you will decide it says is the 144,000 a
literal number of people who will be
alive when Jesus returns all right good
question the church has no fixed
position whether it's literal or
symbolic either way you're on a good
path if symbolic it simply means you
focus on the character of that group
Revelation 14:15 in their mouth was
found no Gile for they are without fault
Before the Throne of God that's the
character now whether or not 144,000
could also refer to the the Perfection
yes 12 12 per perfect people some
believe it is
literally
144,000 I have no problem either way
I've never committed myself to studying
it to figure out which one it is so
there there are two positions in the
church literal and
symbolic and also the 70 years prophecy
I just want to say that it says um
Chronicles says them that have escaped
the sword carried away to Babylon where
there were servants to him which is
Nebuchadnezzar and his sons until the
coming of the kingdom of of Persia to
fulfill the number of years by Jeremiah
which is the land Sabbath in 2
Chronicles so the 70 years prophecy in
Babylon is literal it's a land sabath
because God drove Israel out of the land
so the land could rest and the the
number of years according to Daniel
chapter 9 2 Chronicles 36 is 70 literary
years all right okay all right okay yes
so you said that you want to defend the
faith yes I'd like to yeah if he allow
yeah have you noticed lately that the
Seventh Adventist Church has been
swirling around in a lot of different
circles in terms of being cultist
in terms of uh even I think yes a couple
days ago um there was a certain person
that
certain um journalist that said that
Ellen White and the Seventh Day
Adventist Church are the cause for the
dietary the bad dietary that system that
we have in America oh I didn't know that
okay today so so when you hear these
type of things and the fact that the
seven adven church is a cult how how
would you then defend that what process
would you go through in terms of
Defending that well as for the charge of
being a cult is very simple what is a
cult a cult is a group that is that that
rotates around one charismatic
person and that person exercises
dominance over the group literally tells
the group what to do and what not to do
a cult is built around one person
whether it's David Kesh who perish in
the Flames or somebody else the the 7day
Adventist Church is not built around one
person at all the 7ay Adventist Church
believes in Jesus Christ as Savior Cults
do not believe that and so we're not a
cult we are I don't want to say we're
mainstream either because we're supposed
to be different from every other church
on the face of the Earth but with
respect to the secular definition of
cult the 7 Adventist Church is not a
cult it is not it does not revolve
around Ellen White it revolves around
Jesus Christ
mhm and the Bible is it it's it's a book
of reference the Bible thus say the Lord
is our Authority now the Bible is not
the Authority for the Catholic church so
you want to call somebody a cult call a
Catholic Church a cult it revolves
around the pope not the 7day Adventist
Church we are built around Jesus Christ
and thus sayth the Lord not around Ellen
White or Jane Andrews or whomever else
ad Jones okay
and by the way in the ' 50s a uh
Evangelical scholar studied the
Adventist Church he came he met forgot
Martin was his name and he met with high
ranking Adventists in the general
conference to answer this particular
question he was writing a book on Cults
and he came away with the conclusion the
assembly Adventist Church is not a cult
all right uh
yes good afternoon yes sister Cameron
how are you good how are you no
complaints thank you um what is your
understanding on the matter of if Jesus
had died the second death or not okay if
what is my understanding of if Jesus
died the second death or not the Bible
says the wages of sin is death the soul
that sinth it shall now did Lazarus die
did he come back did he die again now do
you come back from the death that is the
punishment for sin no now how Christ
came back that's mystery of mysteries
right Christ died the death that is the
penalty for sin Lazarus died the death
that is the consequence of sin do you
understand the difference there's a
death that's the consequence of sin
there's a death that's the penalty for
sin no living being outside Christ has
ever paid that penalty amen so Christ
paid that penalty in some mysterious way
he came back to apply the benefits of
that Victory to us so that that's the
death that Christ paid not the one
Lazarus died people die all the time no
you see if it was the death Lazarus died
then he died for his own sins are you
following me Paul would have died for
his own sins only Christ has tasted that
death for every man according to Hebrews
2:9 and he came
back conquering death because the great
enemy is death The Last Enemy that shall
be destroyed is death all right thank
you
yes
laar Lazarus died
twice if lazarus's death is the penalty
for sin then he didn't pay it or he paid
it for himself are you following me only
Christ can pay the penalty for sin the
death we die is the consequence of being
limited or finite anything finite Must
Die
you looking at me
strangely all right anything let me make
it clearer for you anything finite
touched by sin Must Die not only people
including the
world go to the Bible Hebrews 1 you
don't believe but I'm glad you don't so
you can go to the Bible Hebrews
1 let's read from verse 10 this is God
the Father
speaking Hebrews 1: 10 to 12 read
microscopically when you found it say
amen amen now remember this is God the
Father speaking to the son interesting
exchange and thou Lord come on in the
beginning has laid the foundation of the
earth and the heavens at the work of thy
hand so we have Earth and we have Heaven
do you see the word beginning yes now
say Genesis 1:1 for me in the beginning
God created the Heaven and Earth so
that's Genesis 1:1 Now read verse 11
they shall yeah but thou now wait a
minute now if they perish it means they
are
limited the opposite of that is Christ
but thou remainest what is God saying
about Christ un he's
Eternal they Shall Perish but thou
remainest and they all shall wax all as
that a garment and as a vesture verse 12
shall thou fold them up and they shall
be changed but are the same and thy
years shall not fail Christ is eternal
but his creation cursed by sin will
perish anything touched by sin must
cease to
exist whether it's a human being or the
entire world this world if it lasted
long enough must
self-destruct Revelation 211 and I saw
what a new Heaven and a new why a new
Heaven and a new Earth the old ones have
to be destroyed because they are tainted
by sin this body has to be destroyed it
is Tainted by
sin the reason why the only thing that
goes from Earth to Heaven is our because
a character formed like Christ is not
tainted by
sin now the death Lazarus died was not
the penalty for sin because he would
have paid for his own and you can't do
that only Christ can do that the Death
Christ tasted was the death the second
death as mentioned in Revelation 20 a
few times all right uh who is come to
the mic come to the mic let's hear the
quality of your voice hello I don't know
how you do it I got nervous just walking
up but God is good yes he is um I have a
question what would you say to someone
who says that they don't want religion
but they just want a relationship with
God all right okay go to Matthew 16 have
heard that before I want a relationship
I want no religion all right go to
Matthew
16 you have Matthew 16 amen we read the
passage as familiar let's read verse 16
when Jesus said but whom do men whom do
ye say that I am read verse 16 what does
that
say Simon Peter answered and said what
thou are the Christ the son of the
Living God keep reading Jesus answered
and said what Thou Art Peter blessed
thou Simon bar Jonah for Flesh and Blood
hath not revealed it unto thee but my
Father which is in heaven go on I say
unto thee thou and Upon This
Rock H wait a minute now and Upon This
Rock come on I Church does God have a
church does he have a religion yes you
cannot separate God from his
religion go to Ephesians
5 listen to Christ in the church
Ephesians 5 let's read from verse 25
that's a very good question by the way
I've heard it give me Jesus Keep
religion Jesus has a religion and it
comes with him do you have Matthew 5 not
Matthew sorry Ephesian 5 read from verse
25 with me husbands love your wives even
as Christ also loved the church now we
have the Christ's love for the church as
the model of the husband's love for the
wife so keep the church in mind and gave
himself for it that he might sanctify
and cleanse it with the washing of Water
by the word that he might presented
himself a glorious church not having
spot or wrinkle or any such thing but it
should be holy and without blemish so
ought men to love their wives
at own bodies keep reading he that
loveth him for no man ever yet hate his
own flesh but nourisheth it and cherish
it even as the law of the church so it's
we're understanding how Christ loves the
church now read the next verse for we
are members of his body of his flesh and
of his
bone next
verse this is a great mystery but I
speak concerning Christ come on
and the
church when you come to Christ you
become a member of his
church you cannot have Christ and not
his church go to Acts chapter
7 gu the word religion given a bad name
it has a yes the word religion has a bad
name and it's not God's
fault it is not God's fault the word
religion has a bad name m do you have
acts chap 7 amen read verse 38 for me
listen very carefully and see if you
find what I think you should find read
for
me this is he that was in the church in
the wilderness stop to whom is the
author of Acts
referring the the Wilderness in the the
church in the
wilderness the church in the
wilderness the Israelites
they are called by Luke what a
church now let Exodus tell us the same
thing even though the word church does
not show up go to Exodus
19 cannot have Christ and not his
church because his church is his
representative on the face of the Earth
and you disregard Christ Church you've
disregarded Christ and we'll see that in
a minute do you have Exodus 19 let's
read from verse 4 read with me what does
it say ye have seen what I did unto the
Egyptians and how I bear you on Eagle
wings and brought you unto myself now
therefore if you will obey my voice
indeed and keep my Covenant then ye
shall be a peculiar treasure unto me
above all people for all the Earth is
mine next verse and ye shall be unto me
come on a kingdom of priests come on and
a holy nation stop that's the church
amen the entire nation was to be a
church and Luke properly calls them a
church the word Church in the New
Testament Ecclesia means called
out Christ has a people whom he has
called out he separated from the world
according to Ellen White how does he
separate them the messages of the first
second and third angels to have Christ
is to have his church now Christ may
have to leave lead you to that church
you may just meet him not realizing he
has a church but if he controls your
life he will lead you to his church and
his church respects all 10 commandments
amen who's next
yes the word religion is it in the Bible
religion yes yes Galatians chap 1: 13
you have heard of my conversation in the
Jews Rel ReliOn yes Galatians
1:3 hi but Church occurs that word
occurs very seldom church church church
church church word religion
the uh good question I don't remember
the Greek word for it yeah speaking of
relationships I have two questions yes
one being as Adventists should we be
advocating for courtship or dating
courtship and dating or dating or dating
should we be advocating for courtship or
dating well if you accept the counsel of
God's servant to us courtship yes not
long courtship mhm but courtship yes uh
when you have you can't have courtship
without dating you just date to the
glory of God okay you following me you
date to the glory of God by the way
Isaac never dated he just married
Rebecca uh so I've never seen any
evidence of dating in the Bible true but
um dating is proper courtship is proper
you see say courtship is not a
recreational activity correct it's
serious business mhm if you don't plan
on marriage don't Court yes don't date
yes ah you don't like me anymore if you
don't plan on marriage don't date amen
don't Court what's the point are you
following me from the biblical
perspective Elis councel courtship is
the pathway to marriage corre yes and it
should be pursued by responsible people
M that's why it shouldn't belong yes if
you're 16 17 well you need years and
years but of course yes okay next
question well you just said that um
dating is not mentioned in the bible
which is according to my research and um
might I share that according to what
I've come across that dating is
correlated with instantaneous it's it
doesn't end up in marriage more often
because it's more of like a here I am
with you today and tomorrow will not be
however with courtship wouldn't it be a
more like you said wise decision to make
but
then people who are courting what do
they
do they're getting to know each other do
they go out get to know each other yes
do they go to church together yes they
study the Bible all that's dating you
going to church can be a date are you
with me amen forget the movie house and
a bar go to church as a date okay so
yeah dating is part of it but under
God's control through the Holy Spirit M
okay well here's my second question um
us living in today's society especially
with hookup culture being so prevalent
what culture hookup culture hook culture
yes it may not be a term that is well
known but it's basically where intim
physical I can't call it intimacy
because physical intimacy that's not
well it's beyond that I believe that
when it comes to marriage the gift that
God gives a man and a woman is Beyond
sex comes down to emotional intimacy so
hookup culture is basically where people
physical involvement that's it okay yes
and that's it so with that being
prevalent what does courtship what can
it look like for us how can we vindicate
God's name in that manner my
recommendation is that you read the book
messages to young people where Ela has a
section on courtship okay for she has a
she she'll tell you more effectively
than I can so I Rec get that book and
she has a section
on Christian courtship okay well since
I'm up here one more yes we won't charge
you thank you
um as a young person yes being myself
yes um the idea of being with someone we
no one can people need to stop lying to
themselves about you know not looking
forward to the future but in the weight
what is your encouragement for us young
people when especially you know when we
are not ready cuz you mentioned 1615 and
we have children who are in the dating
game that makes no sense so what would
be your encouragement especially to us
young ones in what age group you talking
about well teenagers high school and
teenagers 13 to 19 well okay well why
they tell a 19y old I won't tell the 13y
old what I'm trying to say is that even
at that age they're thinking of that MH
and oh yes all right what I would tell a
Christian teenager you see God in the
Bible what does seven represent
Perfection Perfection let's count the
teenage years is that it yes thank you
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 how many years
seven you have a perfect span of time to
learn how to be what an
adult you're
learning to be an adult but not any
adult what kind of adult a Christian
adult yes now as you get to the later
teenage years that may involve yes
someone
else are you following me and so while I
can't give details as to what the dating
should be it must never be done outside
of this overarching principle to the
glory of God Amen and both should be
drawn closer to Christ because of the
Union at the courtship level
oh yes yeah James 127 also has word pure
religion undefiled yes very good thank
you so we have two James 127 Galatians
okay okay we go ahead I have some
biblical questions I'm not getting them
okay in Amos it says with a plum line I
shall measure My People Israel mhm I
shall not pass by them
a second time a plum line is used to see
whether a wall is straight or not it
always points straight up and down God
says he's not going to judge his people
a second
time in Revelation 11 we read these
words and there was given me a re like
unto a rod and the angels stood saying
rise and measure the temple of God and
the Altar and them that wor ship
therein but the court this is my
question but the court which is without
the temple leave out and measure it not
for it is given unto the Gentiles and
the holy city shall they tread on the
foot month so we know what the Gentiles
are yeah but I want to end it there the
the court in my understanding the court
represents where the lamb was slain
justification is this scripture tell
telling us that there will come a time
when justification will not be enough
cuz it said leave it out it is given to
the Gentiles during the judgment and so
if you're still in the court and not in
the sanctuary all right then you are
lost and will Babylon finally reach the
point where they're just in the court
sacrificing okay but not going all the
way with Jesus okay all right we have
justification sanctification and
glorification you cannot stay at
justification you have to grow that's
the difference not the diff well the
difference is a good word difference
doesn't mean conflict difference
emphasis between James and Paul Paul's
emphasis is justification what happens
the moment you accept Christ something
happens immediately James says now where
is the evidence of that are you with me
so James says show me the evidence that
what Paul said happened actually
happened in your life now this is
sanctification you have to move from
just justification through S that's
constant growth second Peter 3:18 grow
in Grace you have to
grow that's taught to us in creation a
seed produces growth you must grow and
grow and grow under the measure of the
stature of the fullness of Christ and
that means growing and grow so you
cannot stay at justification ification a
person who stays at justification has
not really been Justified because
justification changes your way you think
it changes your relationship to God and
His law you move on now living the life
of a Justified person which is what we
call sanctification which goes this way
it eventuates in glorification but even
on the other side we will grow and grow
because we can never reach the absolute
fullness of the perfect righteousness of
Christ but we grow and grow uh education
page 18 paragraph 4 higher than the
highest human thought can reach is God's
ideal for his children say it with me
now godliness godlikeness is the goal to
be reached and that is a constant
movement towards godliness and comfort
and coverage page 21 paragraph 5 God
created man for his own Glory that as a
test and trial the Human family might
become one with the Heavenly family it
was God's original intention somehow to
combine Humanity with divinity and he'll
still do that sometime down the road
what kind of creature that produces from
our side is just beyond my imagination
when he will combine Humanity with
divinity it will not lower Divinity it
will Elevate Humanity level the angels
have never seen but we cannot stay at
justification there's a reason why
there's something called
scientification constantly growing and
what what causes you to grow study and
Obedience of the word of God somebody
else Ellen White says the vast majority
of God's people are Inon okay and
they'll come out okay so does that mean
this has not happened in in the future
time they're still Sav but in the future
time the court yard will be left out say
that again
justification they will not be safe they
have to make a change yes have to call
them out yes uh John 10:16 he'll call
them out would be future to this okay
have to come out of the Court we have to
come out of Babylon yeah all right okay
that's what the loud cry does is for
people in Babylon call them out God's
people out yes all right good Afternoon
brother so I have a question
um I've heard it throughout the
Adventist Church that it said that the
close of probation will happen for
Adventist
before uh the rest of the world or so
but um through my biblical understanding
I know that once Jesus stands up he who
is righteous let him be righteously and
so do you what is your thoughts on that
teaching I've heard it but I've never
all right go to ro uh 1 Peter chapter 4
let's read verse
17 1 Peter
4:17 do you have it
ah he has often heard that judgment
probation closes for Adventist
first is that
true and I'm trying to provide what I
think is the basis why some Adventists
believe that you have 1 Peter chapter
4:1 17 amen amen let me pray again
father as I continue or we continue
guide us guide us through the spirit of
wisdom father in Jesus name amen read
verse
17 for the time has come that judgment
must begin where at the house of God and
if it first begin at us what shall the
end be of them that obey not the gospel
of so we have obey Again by the way all
right judgment begins at the house of
God are you with me in Ezekiel 9 when
God told the destroying Angel to begin
where yes at the San yes begin with his
people yes not just his people but the
leaders of his people start with them
and so he has judgment begin with God's
people and then moves on so there seems
to be when he's finished with God's
people then probation with them will
close I Don't Preach as a Doctrine but
it seems to be some reasoning behind
that belief but I'm not familiar with
whether the church officially teaches
that or not I am not so I can't make a
definitive statement but I can tell you
this if you die tonight your probation
has
closed are you with me so while it is
legit legitimate to study probation on a
worldwide basis what is more critical is
that ELO says every day every hour
people are passing beyond the reach of
Mercy every day every hour there are
people who come to church on Sabbath
probation is already closed but they're
driven by the force of
habit when Saul rebelled against God God
said in 1st Samuel 15 I've also rejected
you then in verse 14 of chapter 16 and
the spirit of the Lord departed from
Saul but he stayed on the throne a few
more years but the spirit of the Lord
had departed from
Saul and and and also brother when the
mark of the beast crisis uh comes to the
world uh 7eventh Day Adventist who know
the truth would have to make their
decision almost immediately and when you
make the your decision is that's pretty
much final so that's why that's why I
said that probation closes for seventh
day event is first because we understand
these truths it's extended for those who
don't understand God gives them an
opportunity to learn but for us who
know we we it will close for us sooner
than for them okay all right what's that
question online why don't you go ahead
online all right then we'll come to my
brother over
here all right I'm eaching to answer
those questions but I think I'll refrain
myself um because this one on probation
it's I mean the Jews leaders they Clos
probation for themselves first although
for the nation it was still extended so
okay all right um we have three
questions one goes back a little bit on
a topic that you already answer but
still says how do we encourage the
singles so that they don't run to
worldly relationships okay all right
let's uh with that one go to Genesis 6
let me give you some bad
news Genesis
6 you have Genesis
6 we read from verse one tell me when
you found
it amen read with me and it came to pass
when men began to multiply on the face
of the Earth and daughter was born unto
them that the sons of God saw the
daughters of men that they were fair and
took them wise of all which they chose
and the Lord said my spirit shall not
always strive with man for that he also
is flesh yet his days shall be 120 years
keep reading there were giants in the
earth in those days and also after that
when the sons of God came in unto the
daughters of men and they be children to
them the same became what Mighty Men
which were of old men of renown The
Offspring of that mixed marriage we get
impression we're not good people
mighty man let's look at a mighty man
clearly came from mixed marriage go to
Genesis
10 Genesis
10 are you right there verse eight read
for me and Kush begat Nimrod he began to
be a mighty one in the earth he was a
mighty Hunter before the Lord come on
therefore it is said even as Nimrod the
mighty Hunter before the Lord now we
have an example of a mighty
one now while it doesn't state it
clearly but we go back to the mighty one
in verse four of Genesis 6 we know zrod
was the founder of the first Kingdom
which is a collection of cities Babel
Eric C Aid and K in the land of Shina we
know Cain was the found of the first
city Nimrod the first group of cities NE
there's a mighty one in the earth and so
there's evidence that here's an example
of a product from a marriage that should
not I'm not saying all products from
marriages of that kind are disastrous
I'm not saying that but I'm saying
there's evidence of a mighty one
mentioned in verse four of Genesis 6
being uh expressed in the life of uh
Nimrod in Genesis 108 and N but I want
you to notice if you read the first
three verses of Genesis 6
now let us look at verse 11 and verse 12
of Genesis
6 the Earth
also Genesis 6 11 and 12 what does that
say the Earth also was corrupt before
God and the Earth was filled with
violence verse 12 and God looked upon
the Earth and behold it was corrupt for
All Flesh had corrupted his way upon the
earth
now we have no clearly identified
expressions of
corruption except one
one go back to verses 2 and three tell
me what that one is
amen unequally
yolked is the only one clearly
identified now there were many yes this
one for reasons best known to the Holy
Ghost is
identified read ELO's chapter in Petri
and Prophets uh Enoch and
um Seth yes thank you she said that
Union produced the worst results the
sons of God with the daughters of
men now go to 2 Corinthians hope the
person who gave the question is
listening online 2 Corinthians 6 quickly
quickly quickly you have 5 Seconds to
find it amen you're Adventist you're
Adventist or you look so you have it now
amen all right you know it very well
read verse 14 for me what does that say
be not an equally yoke together with and
believe for what ha righteousness with
unrighteousness and what communion hath
light with Darkness what's the
answer none
amen now why does Paul use that uh
symbol go to Genesis
1 go to Genesis 1
let's read from verse three come on read
with me and God said let there be light
and there was light and God saw the
light that it was good now and God
divided the light from the darkness God
called the light day the darkness he
called night the evening of the morning
with the first day so we have light what
else do we have which one is called good
light
mhm not Darkness not
what did God do to light and
darkness in creation we have a built-in
lesson light and darkness should not
coexist
amen now Paul takes that and he applies
it to
relationships what communion have light
and the answer is none now go to Exodus
34 God is warning the Israelites through
Moses Exodus
34 let's read verse 15 and verse
16 of Exodus 34 Read With Me what does
that say lest thou make a what Covenant
with the inhabitants of the land and
they go a whoring after their gods and
do sacrifice and their gods and one call
thee and thou eat of a sacrifice now God
tells don't don't don't form covenants
with the unbelievers by the way that's
not just marriage it is business
Arrangements is this mic
working
yes okay it includes because if you read
Deuteronomy I think is seven it says no
covenants and no
marriages it states both and El tells us
do not form business Arrangements
with unbelievers they do not have the
same
principles I'll come to you in a minute
and so for those listening online God is
very clear but here's a real frightening
statement if you respect the writings of
el white take a deep
breath Adventist home page 67 paragraph
1 what did I
say I'm not going to tell you it's too
rough no you you're too young
no okay you forc me okay listen
carefully to connect with an
unbeliever is to place yourself on
Satan's ground you grieve the spirit of
God and forfeit his protection what does
forfeit mean you give it
up you give it
up the compy you grieve the spirit of
God and forfeit his protection I did not
write
that adst home page
67 paragraph
1 if you are Baptist marry a
Baptist if you're Jehovah's Witness
marry a Jehovah's
Witness if you're Satanist marry a demon
are you with me if you're not
if you're an Adventist come on finish my
Words
Mar a good one a good
one a good
one I tell
you uh well let me not get on that
anymore all right so my counsel to you
wait on the
Lord listen to this these words of
mine marriage
reveals what courtship
conceals the reality of marriage
dissolves the fantasies of
courture you're talking to a man who's
always counseling
couples I'm no expert I'm simply tell
you what I have experienced
I can't tell you how many ladies have
said to me this is not the man I courted
yes he
is but ladies don't kill me ladies have
this capacity for
hoping that a lion will become a lamb it
does not
work are you with me lions do not become
Lambs an abusive boyfriend will most
likely be an abusive husband
once is
enough something shouldn't happen once
trust God to find you a partner do not
make the search for a partner a God Amen
some let me pick on ladies again because
that's what I've observed some ladies
are so obsessed with getting a husband
it becomes a god it affects every other
area of their lives they can't eat they
can't sleep they can't drink they can't
find the Book of Revelation you know
it's
just they're so obsessed with this thing
I need a man I need a husband no no no
no no Thou shalt have no other gods
before me put the matter before God obey
God you will be shocked because you are
his daughter and he wants what's best
for you he'll find you a husband like
Jesus come on say
Amen don't go look by the way there for
this cause shall a man leave his father
and mother you don't go
looking men go looking not
you so
please now let me leave that alone
I I tell you ah we bring trouble on
ourselves and then we go crying to
people help me you're you're you're
raising some doubts here so I know you
said that like white doesn't with
Darkness even when it comes to business
yes but say if like someone got in a
business with with a that wanted to
pursue Christ but then they kept falling
back and well you see wanting to pursue
Christ is one thing well what if we see
like the uh like improvements and stuff
we see like no no no get into business
with a Seventh Day Adventist about whom
you've
prayed because not all 70 adst are
trustworthy are you following
me many are called few are chosen and
few remain faithful but did you be a
witness to that person yeah yeah yeah no
that's what that's what women say when
they have non-adventist
boyfriends not marri I it's a kind of a
marriage it's a you're associating
you're combining your interest you're
working towards the same
thing get a committed child of God who
does not need the principles explained
are you with me don't make that mistake
please you will suffer
guaranteed either now or
eventually yes
yes okay listen to me God's lifestyle is
vastly different from the lifestyle of
the earth
amen when you get serious about God's
lifestyle people would think you're
extreme haven't we seen your lovely face
before just we're on the same subject
sorry just real quick just real quick no
okay no but let me finish it him let me
no but the question several people in
okay okay okay no you're real quick real
quick did Adam search for his wife did
Adam search cuz you said women don't
search for your wife I'll get so did
Adam search for wife I'll get to that
I'll get to that
okay a slick sister we have here
okay I'll get to that I yes what's the
next question okay the next question is
and is I think it has to do with with a
sermon that you from this morning says
can you explain how a loving God can get
Roth full and Destroy can a loving God
get wrathful and
destroyed yes it was a loving God who
gave his son to die for
you his love for you is so great he was
willing to lose Jesus in order to get
you that's a love in God that love in
action he gives up what's most important
to him
that he may acquire you and me let me
say it again God was willing to lose
Jesus if that was a pricee to win you
that's loving God
mhm
sacrifice is a part of love where
there's no sacrifice there is no
love God is a loving God yes and God
knows thank you
asan all right next question okay the
next uh because that's true that's true
let me clarify the online people are
there for a long time they cannot I
don't want the sister to call the police
so let's see what let's get her question
oh there's people before her oh oh there
are people before
her oh yes come brother come come come
give him a break come yes come come come
come thank you for your
fellow oh
oh
um my question is this uhhuh I can't
give you the reference okay sry but the
passage is in that day seven women uhhuh
will take hold of one man uhhuh
and they will say we will eat our own
bread give us his name we will wear our
own apparel uh-huh just let us be called
by his name right right to take away our
approach so that's my question uh but
I'd like to address something that just
go ahead came up go
ahead
um I have a presentation MH that was
made at the Boon 7th Day Adventist
Church
okay I arranged that presentation MH and
it was made by a family that I'm
studying with in BO okay uh the guy is
the air nose and throat specialist all
right okay has three daughters mhm he
and his wife were not raised in
Christian homes okay became Christians
after they were married MH and decided
that they didn't want their three
daughters M to find husbands through the
same system that they as unconverted
parents right and most Christians had
used and when they told me the story it
was so phenomen I says you have to put
this on tape so others can benefit from
okay all right I have that presentation
which I would like to share I also we
also have a book at the store that was
written by the oldest
daughter very biblical on this issue of
dating and
courting um one thing I'd like to say
for Adventist M if you are not prepared
to stand on the word of God mhm and the
counsel mhm I don't have much hope for
you okay all right I understand that in
terms of a relationship or anything else
or anything else if you want to be if
you are a man or a woman and you want a
Godly
spouse you need to be a Godly person
first yes yes yes yes yes and if there's
anything worse than not being married is
being married to the wrong
person mhm mhm my wife and I have been
married for 50 years okay all right and
if it were not for our common belief and
faith in God we wouldn't have yes yes
yeah a lot of people can say that M my
question on that Pro on that prophecy MH
oh all right i' I've never studied that
verse I I I don't have an answer for
that I've never studied that verse can I
step in I've never yes yes yes yes yes
yes uh how many periods of the church do
we have seven seven churches MH we are
getting to a period where the church is
being diluted they just want the name
but they don't want the word which is
the bread they don't want to do with any
responsibilities they want to have their
own garment their own righteousness they
just want to be called Christians and
their own and their own Doctrine yes and
their old Doctrine not the bread we
don't need your bread we don't need your
garment we just want to Bear your name
yes now it also says in that day in that
day when we get to the period of the
seven churches and the period that the
righteousness comes to test which is the
period that we are now all right okay
all right okay okay the third question
is um what does the Bible say about
wearing jewelry oh
Lord okay well I'm I'm Don't Kill the
Messenger he just all right is that from
online to
that's okay all right thank you let me
I'll get to that let me get to those
who've been waiting patiently up front
sister
come yes I think it's him oh he was next
all right
come we need someone to tell me who's
next and who's next all
right yes uh two quick questions um what
do you think about um should um you know
the 7day Adventist Church be involved in
um you know um current events like act
the popular thing right now is activism
you have the Black Power
movement that goes on in the black
church you have patriotism that goes on
the white church right and both of them
are religions to me now should we uh get
involved in that and also
um
um because there's one book I I see a
lot of books in Seven Day Adventist
Church on display but there's one book I
don't see it's called the southern work
I looked at it myself but you know
should race relations be be addressed in
the seven day adven Church CU there's
church I look at I'm like yeah that's
the white church and there are certain
parts in certain neighborhoods that say
I'm like I know it's the black church it
seem like they
strategically um placed in certain areas
like in the poor neighborhoods they
going to put the black church there okay
and the Suburban Aries I know to see the
white church and also my uh second
question is uh I had a sister who's uh
who visited the church shared the Three
Angels message and
uh and I how it was and she said it felt
like electure was boring to her so my
question is should preachers you know uh
be concerned how they deliver the
message or like CU there are some
preachers I've heard they'll put you to
sleep all right okay and so should they
be concerned about like you know how
they present the message and some of
them preach too long where you just go
off in space all right okay okay should
the church get involved in
activism we have to first figure out why
did God raise up the seventh day
Adventist Church what is the mission of
this church before we get into uh other
issues that are fine in and of
themselves but are they in any way
connected to the reason why the church
was raised up now our mission is to
proclamation of the first second and
that's the reason why we exist now our
Pioneers were very very uh active in the
opposition to
slavery they were very active and they
wrote about it they took their stand but
it did not get in the way of their
promoting The Three Angels messages you
see someone let's take black black lives
matter okay those committed to that they
are committed they March they committed
they have no interest in the Three
Angels
messages now you have those committed to
whatever patriotism which is fine they
are committed they have no interest in
the Three Angels
messages let me ask that the
question is there any other church that
can preach the Three Angels messages
no is there any of the church that can
give food and
blankets yes but is it good is it good
to give food and blankets yes but are
there other churches that can do that
yes and so why we concerned with easing
suffering we must never lose sight of
the primary Reas reason why the church
was raised up to preach the Three Angels
messages now members must be left to
make the individual decisions you can't
find a 7 adst official position on black
lives
matter or on you know who loves Trump or
who loves Biden you see my kingdom is
not of this
world are you listening to me my and
that's not simp olic this is literal I
am a citizen of the kingdom of heaven
but I care about my neighbor are you
following me so whatever I can do to e
suffering I will do if it does not
distract me from my mission so when a
young man came to Christ Master speak to
my brother that he divide the
inheritance with me I think it's Luke 14
or Luke 12 God said man who made me a
judge or divide over he didn't do it now
is it good to mediate yes Christ said no
that's not my worken I didn't come for
that and so we have to be careful how we
involve ourselves because I've observed
some of us are more passionate about
activist movements than about the work
of the
church I'm not condemning the movements
but the let me tell you what someone
told me you won't believe it a pastor
told me his head Elder was upset the
head Elder said to the pastor you giv me
too much work he taking up my time my
mission is to reelect whomever he wanted
to reelect that's what he said so he
resigned he said my mission is to get
this particular person reelected you're
giving me too much work so he laid aside
the work of the church to get involved
in the kingdoms of this
world yes we live in this world we must
be the salt of the earth we must be the
light of the earth we must be a blessing
on this Earth but we are a greatest
blessing when our heads are in heaven
amen Ela said Abraham was a blessing to
the surrounding Nations but he looked
for a city which had come on Foundation
that's where his mind was if he then be
risen with Christ seek those things
which are above by the way let me tell
you about social
movements the people on the streets
don't really know what the powers are
really doing they don't know they don't
know who is manipulating them so when
you're protesting and breaking down
build buildings and burning cars you
have no clue what the powers behind are
really
doing take black lives matters
y they found out the leaders
were people on the streets getting shot
getting killed and the leaders using the
money for something else the only
movement that you know what's going on
is the
gospel you know what the leaders are
doing father son Holy Ghost you know
other things things you don't know amen
you know only what you're
shown what you what they want you to
know you don't know you just
don't so black lives matter all life
matters amen you know we should be
concerned with oppression and Injustice
yes but White lives matter too Latino
lives matter the eskimos matter the
aborigin is in Australia matter H not
just black amen because sin has no
color sin has no color let me tell you
something in the time of trouble black
lives matter patriotism the Pope the
Illuminati they'll all get together to
persecute
you are you listening to me they'll all
come together and persecute God's
commandment keeping people the world
will be divided into two those who obey
the Sabbath and those who don't or those
who obey God and those who don't that's
it come on Amen Jesus matters amen the
law of God
matters yes Justice matters if my
neighbor is hungry I feed him but I'm
not going to march in Memphis and
there's someone in an arbor who's hungry
I live in an arbor my neighbor is hungry
but I'm marching in
Nashville what did Jesus say he shall be
Witnesses unto me both in Jerusalem and
in all Judea and Samaria and spread out
is there someone in your street who
doesn't know Jesus yet you want to have
a mission trip to the
Philippines are you following me I
cannot tell you what movement to follow
all I'm saying is do you understand why
this church was raised
up all right uh someone else on line I
think hello hi I have a question M um
you were equally yolked and married yes
as with the Adventist uhhuh but in the
marriage um your spiritual growth yes I
guess you with study grew deeper yes
with God and your spouse not so much
lagging Behind still in the
church but um the question is um
how do you maintain a home that is
spiritually divided meaning kids are
involved the kids have chosen sides with
the parent that is not so
spiritual um and it's divided it's it's
a hurting home yeah God is a specialist
at reconciliation and
unifying the spouse who is growing in
Grace and is
outnumbered has to do first maintain the
that honest relationship with Christ are
you with me that person must pray and
pray and pray and avoid condemnation are
you following me uh do they do they
stick around do they stick around yes
yes you can't just get up
believe yes you stick around not just
stick around you're
committed okay so I get that but okay so
the kids have taken sides that's fine
and yes what do you do if no one's on
your side you have God on your side okay
you have God on your side and I'm not
joking I'm serious With God all things
are
possible you fight in God's armor not
yours correct and God loves them who've
taken side against you he loves them
what would be okay prayers is first got
it prayer and study and asking God for
peace and all the above but what would
be the step as far as talking to the
kids do you like talk to them privately
if the spouse is not talking with you
it's like an a you do everything to pres
to keep your children from seeing
division among the parents what if it's
too late well well okay depending on the
age of the children how old are
teenagers who's the youngest one how old
is the youngest one 16 okay so the other
is above that you almost have adults
okay you do whereever regardless of the
age you don't want to publicize division
between mother and father if it exists
and you're the one who's spiritually
mature you do nothing to downgrade your
spouse in the eyes of nothing you
overcome good overcome evil with good
it's a Heavenly principle it works you
go to First Peter chapter 3 Peter tells
women who have unbelieving husbands
respect them as your husband let them
see Christ in you and that will win them
maintain your relationship let that
touch the heart because as the children
grow they will see things they hadn't
seen before Okay so sanity comes from
peace with God yes yes sister okay yes
my sister Isaiah 263 thou will keep him
in perfect peace whose mind is sted upon
thee great peace have they which love
thy law and not yes it is that
connection you see peace I give with you
not as the world giveth give I unto you
the peace of God sustains you in
difficult times but do nothing to make
your spouse look bad in the eyes of the
children nothing amen and don't
leave that leaving is fine okay yes
sister how are you good God bless you
what's your name Malia is that in the
Bible no okay all right go
ahead so a sister wanted to know that if
we are supposed to take care of the sick
on the Sabbath yes who uh why do some
say it's not good to work if you are
getting paid uhhuh if you are doing that
type of work yes and you control that
environment uhhuh uh whereby you can
also remember the Sabbath day and keep
it holy is it considered breaking the
Sabbath you can't remember the Sabbath
day keep it holy while you're working on
the Sabbath right that's like washing
your hands and drying it in dirt you
can't do that right the Commandment says
in it Thou shalt not do any work now
Jesus says it is lawful to do good right
he never said it's lawful to work mhm in
the book medical missionary page 26
paragraph to El advis doctors and nurses
if you have to go in do what's necessary
to ease human suffering whatever money
is given to you give it to the
church because you're not supposed to be
paid for that let me tell you something
else that's frightening when God sent
Mana how many days did he send it six
days what are the days Sunday through
Friday what was the purpose of the Mana
uh so that they're to keep them alive
they had nothing to eat they were
complain they were dying of starvation
the manner is a living are you with me
keeps you alive it did not come on the
Sabbath so if you making a living on the
Sabbath who sending
it because God does not provide on the
Sabbath he doubles up on the day not on
Sabbath so if you're making a living on
the Sabbath it is not from
God you listen to me
we have to be serious about God Amen are
you with me you can't negotiate if you
negotiate the Sabbath you can negotiate
Commandments seven Thou shalt not commit
adultery and you can say in my Society
there are four women for every man so
let me help
Society the moment you rational or or uh
what's the word
uh rationalize one commandment you've
opened the door to rationalize any of
the other nine we must obey God strictly
counsels for the church PID 68 paragraph
5 H white writes the history of God's
dealing with his people in all ages
shows that he requires exact obedience
going to that hospital ease suffering
whatever compensation comes your way
give it to the church you're not
supposed to be paid for what's done on
the
Sabbath I'm sorry and I guess that
answers the second question um her other
question was well what if like someone's
supposed to be working on that day but
she's off on the Sabbath but the person
gets sick or has take care of someone
who is sick in their home then she would
get called in should she go in or should
she not so I guess your answer would be
whatever money she makes on the sabath
to ease someone's suffering people have
to be fed on the Sabbath are you with me
people have to take medication on the
Sabbath no problem they don't work on
the Sabbath right if your husband is
sick would you feed him on the Sabbath
would you give him his medication is
that working
no listen to me strict obedience is this
the
secret you're welcome if you meant it to
me uh is it your turn my sister I think
so well come on up come on up with
confidence I'm all right with that good
what's your question good evening very
simple good first let me say this before
I ask okay somebody told me uhhuh that
it's a
worldwide 7th Day Adventist Church
policy MH that you are not allowed to
serve with long hair long hair yeah no
no no that's not a church poliy no I I
told him that okay go ahead but that's
what he told me uhhuh and uh
then he even anyway
that did Jesus have long hair I don't
know hold
on was Jesus a Nazarite or did he ever
take the Nazarite vow he was a nazarine
yes that's right yes no wait a minute
did he take the Nazarite vow and not cut
his hair for 7 years 14 years or however
longone I've never read if he took a vow
did he drink wine he was at the the
wedding it not alcohol that he drink no
no we know that but it's wine okay
Adventist we know that right okay right
so that's my question though for the
most part because I had a child that
wanted to serve in the church to do a
prayer uhhuh his hair was cornrow back
it okay the child was not allowed to
pray okay the child was broken hurt mhm
MH another child his hair was 2 in long
2 in MH they did not want the child to
pray okay because his hair was long okay
because of this worldwide church policy
okay it's not a church policy I know
it's not but I mostly was concerned
about if Jesus was actually a ma
Nazarite or not well Paul tells us it's
a it's a shame for man to have long hair
well we know that we know that MH do you
think that the Shroud of Turin is a
authentic piece I don't know I don't
think about the shroud of T abely no
clue well never mind that was my
question
okay the Shroud of Turin have you heard
of the sh of Turin yes all right okay
all right thank you sister I mine is uh
I think it's short um so I have heard uh
metaphors of the sanctuary service uhhuh
for health reform mhm dress reform MH
and for marriage
mhm and
I I mentioned one of these to my sister
and she quickly quoted Ellen White verse
which I do not remember not verse but a
quotation that said that we aren't
supposed to use a sanctuary for anything
other than the The Plan of Redemption
okay is that do you know of that I've
never heard that quotation never heard
that never heard that now his purpose is
to teach the Plan of Redemption yeah yes
the gospel is in the sentury that's how
God chose to teach it to the Israelites
from a kindergarten level because having
been in Egypt that long they did not
even remember who God was do you think
it's okay to use it for these other
examples that people use it for such as
for dress reform diet reform and
marriage why not let me give you an
example go to Exodus 282 quickly Exodus
282 Exodus 28 verse two when you found
that read that for me this is a
connection with the sanctuary
and th sh the clothes Aaron was supposed
to wear you have Exodus 282 amen God is
speaking to Moses what does God say and
thou shalt make holy garments for Aaron
for Glory and for beauty now what was
Aaron's
position yeah Are We Now a kingdom of
priests yes all right should we have a
distinct way of dressing yes yes for
Glory first then for beauty so you can
use a sanary event to make a wider
application nothing wrong with that all
now we are Kingdom of priests the high
priest in the days of Aon could not
marry any
woman he couldn't marry a former
prostitute that's right the average man
could he couldn't that's right there
were restrictions on what he could do
now we are Kingdom of priest shouldn't
we be careful yes or no yes so you can
apply it in other areas of life because
the gospel should reach all areas of
life amen and the sanctuary teaches the
gospel another example what forms of
uncleanness can you remember in
Leviticus that existed back then I'll
tell you one if a woman had a male child
she was in clean if she had a female
child she was in clean 14 days for the
man seven if a man had dandruff that was
a form of in cleaniness uh something on
your house mold on your house that was
in cleaness a man had a seminal emission
that's in cleaness uh all forms of
uncleanness and there was a ritual to
clean it to fix it up the only form of
uncleanness for which there was no
ritual to make it clean was unclean
animals that's right are you with me
what lesson does that teach us an
unclean animal then is unclean now so
when God said don't eat the pig it
wasn't just an Old Testament thing it's
Universal it there was nothing that
could have been done to make a pig clean
are you following me it was unclean then
it's unclean now now when I say unclean
I mean for
food Adventists are strange people
sometimes a pig isn't clean for food but
for some reason we view a pig as the
most unclean animal on
earth we won't touch a pig but we'll hug
a dog and kiss it on the
mouth and a dog is unclean for food yes
or no yeah we kiss our
dogs and we spit at
pigs are you with me yes we hug rabbits
and they're unclean we hug the horse is
unclean but we won't touch a pig why
not what's
that you're not a pig kind of guy but
you're a pork kind of guy
okay H pork smells nice that's what they
say okay who's
next yes sister what's your name uh
kazaya who kazaya yes kazah my question
is for for the Youth yes is there any
advice you can give when it comes to
building a relationship with Jesus
building a relationship with Jesus with
Jesus
this yes it's simple Kai this you see
this is food this is drink this is
divine power you know how Christ cast
out demons Matthew 8:16 he cast out the
spirits with his word how did he make
the universe with his word how does he
suain the universe with his word how did
he forgive the woman he said it his word
how did he raise Lazarus with his word
this is how you build that you study and
Obey yes sir is there any like specific
books that you could give start with
John start with oh let me tell you why I
always recommend John let me pray
father I believe we're coming close to
the end of this but still be with us I
pray in Jesus name amen go to John 20
quickly thank you Kaz God bless you
John
20 what time is
it 5 what tell me you're
joking
5:15
okay how are you no not yet not yet not
yet John
20 do you have John 20 read verses 30
and 31 for me they contain why I
recommend John now you must read
microscopically and think as you read
look at what you're reading come on
start reading and many other signs did
Jesus truly in the presence of his
disciples stop when something is done in
the presence of someone else what do you
have you have
witnesses John said Jesus did many the
word signs mean miracles in the presence
of his so in other words they could
check John if he said anything wrong are
you with me keep reading which are not
written in this book now John said I saw
Jesus do all these things since Jesus
was a good man he never did anything bad
so everything John saw was good keep
reading but these are written stop what
did John
do but yes he wrote but look at what he
said he said I saw Christ do a lot of
Miracles that I didn't write about but I
wrote about the
what did he do selected he
selected he said okay this miracle no
it's good but no that Miracle no no I'll
choose this one this will make my point
this one good no I'll choose this one he
selected and in John there only seven
miracles before Christ Rose from the
grave seventh one after he rose but
usually John is said to have seven
miracles that's all the book with the
fewest Miracles but these are written
now why did he choose the ones he has
and other events keep reading that you
might believe uh-huh Jesus Jesus is the
Christ come on the son of the Living God
and that leaving you might have what is
the very stated purpose of the Gospel of
John your salvation now all 66 books yes
but John puts it right in your face I
wrote this book if you study it and Obey
of course you'll be saved amen
amen I always recommend John another
reason it was written by the disciple
closest to Christ he lived longest he
also wrote Revelation El says of all the
disciples he eventually most perfectly
reflected the character of Christ so I
always recommend John number one yes my
brother I'm Samuel you're who Samuel oh
samel is a good powerful yes it is MH
bless you and uh I have a question if we
going to believe in all the Ten
Commandments yes that's what God said we
need to do uhhuh and we're going to
stand on the word of God
yes and it doesn't matter we got
sometimes we got to offend some people
to tell the truth that's true that's
true that's true I want to know
something uh-huh is it scriptural M for
a woman M to preach in a p pit okay is
it scriptural for a woman to preach in
the pulpit and you started with the Ten
Commandments well you know the it's not
in Ten Commandments but it is a you know
it is a scripture it's okay all right
well it looks like
it there is a text where it says let the
woman keep silent in the church it is
one of the most Troublesome texts in the
Bible El white has no comment on it as
far as I know and the Adventist Church
has no position on it but we know that
elen white preached in all kinds of
pulpits in the 7 Adventist Church she
had no opposition to other people
preaching now we also know from
Philippians chapter 4 there were two
women who assisted Paul in evangelism
Yus and C we know in Acts 18:2 24-26
there was a woman called Priscilla who
taught Apollos more perfectly Apollos
was ex was eloquent did not know the
Bible so they took him aside and they
taught him more perfectly a woman did
that and so we have evidences of women
leading now in numbers 4 and 5 we have
Deborah who was a prophet she had to
speak publicly she had to deler deliver
so we have biblical evidence of women
speaking now the Bible also tells us a
woman prophesying with her head
uncovered okay prophesying means
speaking for God yes so there's evidence
women can speak for God so whatever let
the woman keep silence in the church it
does not mean that a woman cannot stand
in the church and speak and the 7day
Adventist Church is not opposed at all
to women speaking in the church okay
what about if they speak down here
like sometimes we had one here the other
day they spoke here and they spoke up
there too is it okay for them to speak
here but not up there I no I have no
position on that no no no no no no no I
want to leave this place alive no I have
no I have no position on that I hear
that thank you brother Samuel God bless
you you're wearing a blue shirt blue
pants in the Bible blue is the color of
obedience good color Yes sister so
you're known as a pastor who memorizes
the Bible no no just two or three
verses um so do you have any tips to
share yes yes yes yes because we know a
bibles are going to be taken away so we
can commit scripture to memory here's
another thing I told God thank what's
your
name asanta a Santa spell it a s o n t a
oh aanta okay sister
asanta there's another thing I told God
I told you I ask God let me be arrested
so I can defend the truth another thing
I ask God if someday you need someone in
a Muslim
country who can't take a
Bible consider me yeah consider me and I
said I'll put it here so if they ask me
do you have a Bible I can say no because
they're asking for do you have a hard
Bible there's not a reason why I put it
in my head in fundamentals of Christian
education page 473 paragraph 2 L white
writes these
words great trues that have laay
unseated un seen and unheard since the
day of
Pentecost unheeded and and unseen since
the day of Pentecost are To Shine from
God's word in their native Purity to
those who truly love God the Holy Spirit
Will Reveal truths that have faded from
the mind and will also reveal truths
that are entirely new when I read I said
father I'm a preacher I prefer to preach
than to
eat can you pick me
to show me Great truths that have laay
unheeded and unseen since the day of
Pentecost what did Paul say what did
Peter say that no one knows now please
tell me and so I started praying that's
many years ago I started praying to God
and then he said the Holy Spirit Will
Reveal truths that have faded from the
mind what are those truths and will
reveal truth that is entirely new it's
so Lord please pick me and so I doubled
up in my memorization of the Bible in El
in case God says to the angel go and
look for
someone that I can give some truth to I
want him to say father we found a guy in
Michigan who loves to memorize he must
love your word pick him now they may not
name me but that's one reason why I do
it but my primary reason is it's a
source of strength now how do I do it
raw repetition
Ministry of healing page 491 paragraph
3 that which is first seems Difficult by
constant repetition grows easy until
right thoughts and actions become
habitual we call that practice makes
perfect we admire athletes Stefan
whatever his name is shooting the three
thrs or uh for those of you old enough
who remember Pelle the soccer player or
who whomever you know uh you name
someone who's very good tiger worlds I
met a professional golf in South Africa
he told me when he was playing he would
hit 600 drives or whatever you call them
a
day so that he would do it without
thinking muscle memory you see if you
have to think it slows you up you have
to do it automatically if you touch a
hot stove you don't think are you with
me you move and so three
600 uh whatever these things are drives
a day I heard somewhere Jordan will
shoot about 1,000 three stor
mhm constant constant
practice so I read it I turn away I
understand what it says first what's the
message and what's the structure of the
verse you see to help me memorize a
friend of mine sent me a very good
friend of mine a a Bible verse just to
encouraged me Psalm 571 I read it read
the whole Psalm liked it I memorized it
then I tried to get him to do it and so
I all
day I don't like to tell people what
I've memorized but I'll give you a
little clue I told you first thing in
the morning I say this Psalm Psalm 119
first thing in the morning Psalm
119 and then about three times a day I
try to say it three times it used to
take me 13 minutes now it takes me eight
CU you know you fly through it three
times a day so I keep that thing in my
head you know Psalm
119 no you
don't
huh yeah so that's three times a day so
if I brushing my teeth I say it and then
maybe I reserve time for the Old
Testament passages there then New
Testament when I go to the gym as I told
you I may pick a passage and say it over
and over till I get it as the way I know
my name over and over but I understand
what it is
saying and I look at the structure for
instance you're memorizing Genesis 5 the
genealogy and Adam lived 130 years begat
a son in his own likeness after his
image and the days of Adam after he got
Seth were 800 years he beat son and
daughters all the days that Adam lived
for 930 years and he died and that that
style goes for all the Patriarchs so
it's easy now just plugging the numbers
and memorize that chapter and so I look
at how it's written the arch tecture the
style of course I use the King James I
like the challenge of the King James but
I pray and I ask God to help me I pray
but I'll tell you one thing that's worth
more than
gold
discipline it is better to be
disciplined than to be an ill
disciplined
genius
discipline it's raining I do
it there's an earthquake I do it
there's a flood I do it my wife is
beating me up I do it are you with me I
don't care what it is I do it so I
during the night you wake up go to the
bathroom in between wake and sleep I try
to say it can I still concentrate while
I'm sleepy I'm watching the news and I'm
saying as can I say it correctly while
watching the
news so you subject yourself to
distractions and you say it that's for
me are I'm not saying that for you
that's for me but my secret is constant
constant constant practice I recommend
four Deeds one you must have the
desire a lot of us we admire it we don't
desire it are you following me two you
must be
determined a brother said his favorite
vers is John 11235 Jesus swept if that
takes you 6 months you stick with it
Jesus swept 6 months Jesus SW you
finally get it
determination the third one is
discipline no matter what the conditions
are I will do it I think of the Nike
just do it and the fourth one Divine
help desire
determination discipline Divine now
listen to me regardless of your age
try your mind will
change I have grandmothers who
memorizing
I have a friend certain
country she memorized the first 10
chapters of Proverbs now that's a
challenge because virtually every verse
is separate from the other there's no
story so it's a challenge to memorize
Proverbs first there's another lady I
told her you should memorize scripture
she said no I can't I said try no I said
try she tried she memorize first John
all five chapters then she said give me
another one then she did James then she
said give me another one and she did a
uh
Jonah she tried you will be
shocked and as you put that word in your
head physics becomes
easier because you have the word of the
person who invented physics amen listen
to this quotation then I come to an end
Christ object lessons page 125 paragraph
3 all those of you in school listen
carefully if the follower of Christ will
believe his word and practice it there
is no science in the natural world he
will not be able to grasp and appreciate
grasp hear appreciate with a heart are
you following me if the follower of
Christ will believe his word and
practice it every other science becomes
easy constant practice my lovely sister
who asked the question constant practice
try I always recommend King James
because it challenges you you know I'm
always uh amused when people say King
James difficult and I say did you study
languages in high school yes what German
French and and you can't read the King
James version what's your
problem all right uh Dr Magna you're my
boss um how many more questions do we
have one okay we have a young person I'm
sorry we have to cut it because we have
so much we can't let no I'm sorry the
young person we're going to let you go
after that we'll stop okay and um we'll
have a special which you was was
supposed to have earlier we'll have a
special song and then I'll need to talk
to you to see what we do after all right
okay what's your name uh Janelle Janelle
hi Janelle hi Janelle Cameron
yeah so um you had mentioned before that
um a finite uh any finite person um
tainted by sin must come to an end must
come to an end yes um what about like
the people who are in the last days you
know mhm and you know Jesus comes are
they gonna die or what do you mean the
people in the last days like the people
who who are alive yes when Jesus comes
yes do they die are they righteous or
not both I guess okay righteous the
righteous who are alive when Christ
comes will be taken with him 1
Thessalonians 4:16 you know it say it
with me for the Lord himself shall
descend from heaven with a shout with
the voice of the Archangel and with the
Trump of God and the dead in Christ
shall rise first then we which are alive
and remain shall be caught with them in
the clouds to meet the Lord in the air
so shall we ever be with the Lord so the
righteous living will just join him the
righteous dead will come from the grave
the wicked dead will stay dead the
wicked living will be struck down okay
mhm all right but be sure that when
Christ comes he takes you with him J all
right okay amen thank you Dr Magna God
bless you a very touched when I said
what's your favorite verse everyone had
verses continue your love for God's word
and if you do that you live by it you
walk right into the kingdom of
God let the
words of my
mouth the
meditation of my heart be
acceptable Lord to
you may the
songs that I sing
my life and
offering be
pleasing
Lord to
you let my
life being
offering
totally
devoted to
proclaim the
greatness and the power of
your name
your
faithfulness has never changed and now I
live to
say in all I do I want
to
you let the word let the word
my be
acceptable to
May
the
sing Lord
to my heart I give I want
toing Lord to
[Music]
youing let the word word of my mind of
my be acceptable accept
to you may the
song i s i s be pleasing Lord Lord to
you my heart my heart I give I want to
liveing
Lord I want to
be Lord I want to be
pleasing
Lord I want
pleasing pleasing Lord
your
faithfulness has never changed and now I
live to
say all I do I want to hon
you let the words let the words of my
mouth of my MTH be acceptable
I just want to be
pleas I want to be
pleasing
Jes to you all my heart I
Heart To Live
pleasing
Lord I want to be
[Music]
pleas Lord oh let the words of my life
of my be acceptable
Jes I just want to be
pleasing I want to be
pleasing in your sight
Jesus Lord to you all my heart I give my
heart I want
toing
Lord I want to
be
pleasing
Lord to you
to
youing
Lord to
you to you he pleas the
you to
[Music]
be let the words of my
mouth in the meditation of my
heart let my life let my songs be
pleasing
[Music]
Lord Lord
let's B our heads Our Father in Heaven
thank you so much for
everything we owe you every
breath we owe you everything de God
thank you where we've let you down
forgive us give us a greatest sense of
gratitude father now speak through me as
I offer these closing remarks put a
double blessing on all your people who
love you and love your word in Jesus
name I pray
amen let's go to uh Romans chapter
5 let's read verse 5 Romans 5 reading
verse
5 we read 58 and
10 and my remarks will not be long
please don't worry
do you have Romans
5 5 8 and
10 when you found it say Amen not 5 8
and 10 6 8 and 10 my mistake 6 8 and 10
what does six
say for when we were yet without
Strength In Due Time Christ died now
pause we have Christ and we have what
the ungodly those are two
opposites the Bible says Christ died for
the
ungodly there are many Christians who
consider themselves so bad they cannot
be
saved I am have done terrible things to
God how can he possibly forgive me
listen to me Christ died for the
ungodly go to verse eight what does that
say but God commendeth his love toward
us that while we were
sinners Christ Christ died for the
ungodly verse 6 he died for sinners in
verse 8 same thing let repeat it it's
important read verse 10 for if when we
were enemies we were reconciled to God
by the death of his son much more being
reconciled we shall be saved by his life
in verse six he died for the ungodly in
verse eight he died for sinners in verse
vers 10 he died for his
enemies which means regardless of what
you have done in your past life and I
hope my friends are still listening
online Christ came for
you for you go to Matthew
9 Matthew 9 we'll read from verse 10
Matthew wrote to a Jewish audience
mainly that's why his his gospel is
filled with this expression that it
might be fulfilled that which was spoken
of by the prophet he once convince his
Jewish audience that what happened in
the new was prophesied in the old so he
makes that connection constantly he is
preaching largely or writing to a Jewish
audience Matthew 9 reading from verse 10
what does that say and it came to pass
as Jesus sat at meat in the house behold
many publicans and sinners came and sat
down with him and his disciples now
publicans were absolutely hated by the
Jewish Society they hated them the
Pharisees had no time for Sinners many
publicans and sinners came and sat down
with him and his disciples verse 11 when
the Pharisees saw it they said unto his
disciples what why eateth your master
with publicans and sinners it was
offensive to them read verse 12 what
does that say but when Jesus heard that
he said I will have mercy and
not they that be whole need not a
physici but they that be sick yes read
that again they that be whole need not a
physician but they that be now John 3:16
Says for God so loved the world that he
gave his only begotten son to Die For
Whom the world which means the whole
world is
sick are you with me the whole world is
sick Jesus said they that behold need
not a physician that they that are sick
but go and learn what that mean it verse
13 I not come to do
what called the righteous but Sinners to
rep you see if you think you're bad try
to understand you are the reason Jesus
came
so you're
drunkard that's why Jesus came to
deliver you from your
condition and Christ will not undertake
a task for which he does not have the
capability so you're pimp Christ came to
deliver
you there are some people who believe
before I come to Christ I need to stop
this and stop no no no no no do it if
you have that attitude you're trying to
put Christ out of a
job it is Christ's business to make you
stop this and that and now you may
change behaviors you cannot change your
heart are you with me that's the work of
Christ and since all Behavior flows from
within only Christ can change that don't
wait until you're good to come to Christ
come with the cigarettes in your
pocket come with the condom in your
wallet are you following me come with
the drugs in your
socks he will fix
you nobody's
listening this is the you see Jesus
Christ has a speciality it is changing
People well yes we do and they'll stay
until Jesus comes but don't don't stress
about them the church believe said
Christ will change you that is his work
you heard the favorite verse of a sister
who said a new heart also will I give
you a new spirit will I put within you
what did David say in Psalm 51 verse of
create to me verse 10 a new heart oh God
and renew a right Spirit within me
because you and I cannot do
that we can change you can stop smoking
cold turkey you can't change your carnal
nature and so David said creating me the
word create is deliberately used because
salvation is a work of
creation Now creation was done out of
nothing salvation is done out of nothing
because there's no raw material you and
I can offer God and tell him start with
this because the flesh profiteth
nothing I know if my in me that is in my
flesh dwelleth no good thing and so the
way he created physically out of nothing
he changes us spiritually out of nothing
he speaks us into existence spiritually
and so James 1:18 says of his own will
begat he us with the word of Truth 1
Peter 1:23 being born again not of
corruptible seed but of Incorruptible by
the word of God which liveth and abideth
forever my brief message to you is I
don't care how bad you think you are
Jesus Christ can change you what he
cannot do is force you to come to
him what he can do
is what's that knock let me show you how
good God is to knock on my door where do
you have to be at my
door Revelation 3:20 behold I stand at
the door and knock in a because he has
made the first
move and his move is so huge all you
have to do is crack the door and there
he
is he doesn't tell you step up to heaven
he has come down because he knows you
can't come up am and so he comes and
he's come for one reason to change you
when Adam sinned and Eve sinned they
were both lost isn't me carefully Adam
and Eve were lost wrapped in aprons of
leaves they were lost running from God a
saved person does not run from God are
you with
me and when they heard the voice of the
Lord God Walking In The Garden in the
cool of the day and Adam and his wife
hid themselves from the presence of the
Lord God amongst the Trees of the garden
God came to them because they could not
come to him and he issues an invitation
come unto me that's one way he says it
the other way he says behold I stand at
the door and knock If any man open the
door I will come in and will s with him
that means Fellowship it's astonishing
that the Mighty God wants to hang out
with
you this is no joke God wants to
associate with you but because he's a
righteous God he must change you and
through Christ he fixes you so that you
and he might one day have that
Fellowship without anyone in between but
now it is through Jesus
Christ and so Christ's invitation to you
today is come unto me all ye that labor
and a heavy laden finish it I will give
you rest question for you but don't
answer me do you believe
that don't raise your hands how many of
you are carrying a heavy burden don't
raise your hand maybe regarding your
children your spouse your job your
health a family member you found out
you're diagnosed with one catastrophic
disease or another you are carrying a
burden now listen to me carefully Jesus
says what come to me
all ye that labor and a heavy laden
finish it I will give
you and God does not lie I will give you
rest
I personal 1 Peter 5:7 casting all your
cares upon Him for he carth for you
Psalm 55 verse 22 cast your burdens upon
the Lord and He Shall sustain
thee what does sustain
mean
support uphold keep you from
collapsing when you collapse collapse
onto Jesus don't collapse onto the floor
collapse onto
Jesus cast your burdens on the Lord
he'll sustain you that's guaranteed
but when you cast them don't pick them
up
again leave them at his
feet are you following me leave them
let's say your son left the church H
your daughter you go to god father my
son he grew up in Adventist schools he
was a v he left the church I put him
before you leave him
there mhm keep praying leave him before
God and let God figure out how he will
bring him now God may bring him back
limping but he'll bring him back are you
with me when God was finished with Jacob
that midnight battle Jacob never walked
straight again but he was closer to God
are you following me put your burden on
Christ but you can't put the burden from
a long distance you have to come to him
and put it at his feet in trust whatever
your struggle is God can do several
things one he can remove it
entirely two he can change the way you
see
it let me
explain I love Africa very much my
favorite place to preach in the country
of Tanzania there's a mountain called
Mount Kilimanjaro the highest mountain
in Africa tall snow at the top all the
time people think there's no snow in
Africa but there is let's say I'm
walking across the Serengeti which is in
Tanzania and I'm tired and I come to
kilamanjaro and I'm depressed how am I
going to get past this mountain I have
to climb it I am ready to die but if I'm
a mountain climber are you following me
and I come to kill banjaro I say okay
now do I go up this side or that side
how do I approach it because I now have
a challenge I love now my attitude has
changed are you with me because my mind
is different if I'm not mountain climber
I start
crying here's your killer man Jara in
your life you come to God God may decide
to remove it or make you a mountain
climber you have a wife who first cousin
to be elub you go to
God huh you go to God and you pray for
that woman are you following me you pray
for that woman you pray and you pray the
demon out of
her or you have a
husband who's the twin brother to Judas
you do the same thing you pray you pray
why because praying has power what am I
trying to say some of us suffer for no
good
reason there is a God for whom nothing
is imposs and we're
suffering and so here's what the Heathen
have to say when the heathens is
suffering Psalm 115 from verse one not
unto us oh God not unto us but unto thy
name give glory for thy mercy and for
thy truth say wherefore should the
Heathen say where is now their
God they don't have a God they're all
miserable they're all suffering they're
all sick the children all rebellious
where is the
God we must be able to say verse three
our God is in the heavens
he hath done whatsoever he hath pleased
recommit your life to God before he
leave this
place confess your wrong in doubting
him don't doubt
God when Peter began to sing Matthew 14
verse 31 30 and 31 and Christ saved him
you know what Christ said to him oh thou
of little faith what are the next words
wherefore did thou doubt don't
doubt Mark 11:
23:24 verily I say unto you for I say
unto you whosoever shall say un this
mountain be thou removed and be thou
cast into the sea and shall not doubt in
his heart but shall believe it will come
to pass the Ethiopian unic said to
Phillip see here is water what do hinder
me to be baptized Philip said if thou
believest with all thine heart thou
take a risk on God I hate the word risk
but I'll use it take a risk on
God obey him trust him 3 weeks see what
happens do whatever he says three weeks
God will hurry up to show you he's
pleased the expert say if you do
something for 3 weeks it becomes a habit
three weeks whatever he says do it study
obey and put your burden at his feet and
in your mind leave it and stop worrying
about it God's job is to worry your job
is to trust let him worry other I said
he has a thousand different ways to
provide of which we know
nothing if you don't believe me ask
Elijah when he ran from Jezebel he came
to that Brook there were no supermarkets
what did God do he said sent Ravens they
came Faithfully twice a day they brought
whatever they brought and he dve from
the brook God can provide above all he
can save how many will say father I
recommit my life to you can I see your
hand ah God stand up with me God bless
you I really mean it from my heart God
bless
you I want you to do me a favor
doesn't cost any money don't
worry don't be
lost that's my favor do not be
lost lean on
God trust him obey him renew your
surrender every
day believe this more than your own eyes
believe this has bowed eyes closed our
father in Heaven thank you so much dear
God for your love that cannot be
measured unless we think we can measure
Calvary we thank you Father for your
longsuffering
nature we thank you for your quickness
to forgive and to
forget thank you for casting our sins
into the depth of the sea now father we
have stood to recommit our lives to you
dear God your hands are the safest place
for us we place our lives in your hands
we place our problems at your feet our
biggest problem dear God is Not
unemployment or single life it is
Disobedience if we can fix that
everything else will be taken care of
father bless every man woman boy and
girl listening in this building and
online
draw them close to your bosom by this
tireless work of your Holy Spirit
protect them from harm and danger father
heal those who are sick provide
employment for those who are looking
bless those at school help them to do
well and to commit their education to
your glory bless the little children in
a very special way they God because they
learn very quickly father save us all
when you come and until then let us in
our lives be a blessing to others and a
stumbling block To None I offer this
prayer from my heart in Jesus name let
God's people say amen and amen God bless
you I love you for loving Jesus and if
we never meet again on this side let's
meet where on the sea of glass and that
day is coming
[Music]
[Applause]